Kanye West gears up to debut his Yeezy  season 5 collection at New York Fashion  Week monkeys exhausted just really tired  despite reports of Kanye's family being  worried that he's too stressed out a  source close to the all-day rapper tells  ET he's excited for wednesday show quote  Kanye is doing really good he's in a  great place he's focusing on his family  and the line they're all doing well I  mean it's so exciting we're told wife  Kim Kardashian is confirmed to attend  the runway show along with sisters  Kendall and Kylie Jenner I love Kanye  shows I feel like they're so always  super elevated and cool and they inspire  me as for what to expect on the catwalk  a source tells ET Yeezys new line is  super casual at a lower price point I'm  really proud of him it's always nice  seeing his like creative nine to come  out  [Music]  you